[Music]
welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
offline experience that's right we are
no longer live Thank You to KFD KFC our
previous episode was blocked based on
copyright laws and our whole episode was
taken off worldwide first of all let me
thank expressvpn and quip before I go on
this coyote rant that leads us to this
no longer live podcast so last week we
did this whole big episode and it was
two-and-a-half hours long and as soon as
we finished live-streaming we check the
stats and it's blocked worldwide now why
was it blocked worldwide because of that
stupid KFC bobble head routine at Ultra
that fricking EMD EDM they blocked the
whole podcast from a two-minute segment
now why it's not a strike or a claim
it's just gone right when it's blocked
like you can't even access the video
that's right and so let me first of all
explain why this is a huge problem
because we live streamed it we have the
views from the live stream there's about
60,000 views and then after the live
stream ends YouTube sends it out to
people's subscription feed it sends it
up to their home page it sends out
notifications so after all that's gone
out when it gets blocked worldwide all
the notifications and everything is dead
so everyone's going to a dead link and
it just says blocked so basically you've
lost your opportunity to get views so
even if it comes back
you've lost your opportunity they've
essentially killed the video when they
do that especially right after you post
it yeah so I moved it to private you
know I was surprised because I disputed
it immediately and I was expecting the
link to come right back up but what I
found out is that if you get blocked the
video stays down for two whole days
well they considered the dispute and
then such a problem with the podcast cuz
it's a lot of current events and it's
for people it's like part of the
schedule they know it
gonna be on Friday they're gonna watch
it mm-hmm at a certain time and it's
like you're just messing up with
everything it's so evil
I hate these these corporate they're so
evil they don't consider the consequence
of anything they're just putting their
hands and everyone's pockets they're
messing up everyone's business and they
don't care they do it because they can
literally you know just like why
shredder licks his butthole why does he
do it because he can if I could lick my
butthole I may well do it as well I'll
tell you I would I would do it if I
could do things
there's things I would do but um so I
like I start talking to my people at
YouTube and I say what am I supposed to
do I'm trying to run a business the CEO
just came here to visit us the day
before this happened at our office here
to celebrate our achievements and this
business we've built so the next day I
go I'm trying to run a business
I have sponsors I have a crew what am I
supposed to do when I post a video and
it gets blocked for a two-minute segment
that's fair use and a 2 and a half hour
podcast what actually am I supposed to
do
so the solution they offer me they says
listen if you want to avoid this
happening you have to go offline and
here's why you need to post the video
unlisted first and you can see what
claims come in what blocks come in so
that way you can fix it before you post
it and you don't waste the opportunity
like we don't have done we don't even
have that filter when we go live and
that's what we're doing today but this
process is gonna be so annoying yeah
because you got to wait for the claims
to come in and then you gotta maybe make
changes then you gotta react sport the
whole podcast reuploads it's like could
be hours now and then it's Saturday
hours of extra work and then Saturday
you're not done with work well I'm
hoping to get the video up today I want
to finish export it get it up and
hopefully should be up by like three but
takes cuz it's such a long you know
video takes so long to export it and
upload it feels weird that we're not
live do you feel like no I keep thinking
like I want to check the stream nothing
change the stakes aren't as high say
like I could say the n-word right now we
could just cut it I don't know what mom
I know it goes to that the was always
like I'm just gonna be like it's now
like off can you just say no of course
that's just the worst case I'll just be
like you know but now it doesn't nothing
matters anymore but we're not making any
cuts this is how we do it baby you know
how we do it I've been doing life now
for two years I'm a I know I'm a veteran
okay I get in the trenches and I don't
make cuts that's how we roll and you can
expect the same great beautiful rawness
from us that you've come to expect but
essentially KFC has ruined the HD
podcast you know what's so sad that KFC
is actually one of my favorite fast
foods
so now I lost that too I'm a straight-up
boycotting now for the record it wasn't
KFC that took it down I know and this is
the kind of my larger point it was Ultra
who took down the and blocked but well
my larger point is that these brands
that are collaborating and paying them
and partnering with these companies need
to know what they're doing on their
behalf okay kfd paid a lot of money for
all this dumbass marketing they're doing
so stupid yet here we are talking about
it and their idiotic moronic partners at
Ultra block it hello is viral marketing
you morons it's so I heard Joe Rogan
recently went lion as well because for
IE I don't know why he said problems
with YouTube but it's like saying yeah
it's got to be the same thing because
you cannot operate a business like this
it's outrageous and you know it's a
shame there's so much great footage of
this KFC guy know like we couldn't be
watching it every Friday it's like it's
like the new are Kelly in Ethiopia well
I've got some new KFC footage I want to
show you an honor of Mother's Day KFC
redid their Twitter
and I gotta tell you it's time to it's
time to stop it really is time to stop I
don't know
wait why is to say just go away just go
away all right chicken Dale's so the
colonel is now a male stripper and I
don't know who they're catering to I do
not want your chicken anymore no someone
is eating KFC doesn't want this this is
a KFC okay yeah but then they post this
video of male strippers wishing moms a
Happy Mother's Day and they don't even
make sure check it I am gonna start
eating pop buns I heard pop Isis bomb
you know we should order Popeyes why
should we should order Popeyes tonight
and an Instagram story and be like man
this Popeyes is bomb I can't believe
what I'm looking at right yeah well
watch it I'm so pissed
KFC first of all I don't like this viral
marketing these brands need to just shut
up make their poison that we put in our
body against our better judgment and
just just chill dude does this somehow
we're related to my Thursday yeah
because they're both so Chippendales I
guess there's a male strip club so it's
chicken dance and Matt you know you know
how many meetings they had Oh about this
do you know how many people had meetings
about this you know usually I think they
do I think usually they have like a
million meetings and goes through
million layers but with this [ __ ] I
don't think so no I think they're I
think they're trying super hard I think
they think they're marketing geniuses
well let me show you this video okay
buckle up and I'm not gonna pause once I
promise man well I do my best what's the
idea by the way wouldn't Mother's Day
like you're gonna get your mom a bucket
of KFC one man get her male stripper to
[ __ ] the [ __ ] ever cousin Ben [ __ ] good
and like three decades apparently and
then bang I don't know man you tell me
what you've what you like howdy mom here
you all saw me you interpret this
I hear you're the best mom in the world
so the manga is a virtual guy no real
yeah
does that look real to you you up that
looks real me so it's a bunch of male
strippers topless dancing boys there
Jack I don't think it's funny or clever
it's just dumb like how does it feel to
be the coolest mom and the world okay
get to the chicken part yet idiots and
so they thought this was funny yeah I'm
gonna bucket of chicken
yeah mine yikes
that is a big yikes for me I'm wondering
what would my mom think if I showed her
this I could yeah oh look produced under
license from Chippendales this was
actually a collaboration with
Chippendales you actually paid somebody
a license for this idea that's even more
embarrassing do we just got our video
blocked by showing that wait hold on is
this a Chippendales ad no because it is
in collaboration with shipping does it
says at the bottom yeah
this Mother's Day only Chippendales will
be serving KFC I feel like it may be in
some other completely different universe
that could be funny if it wasn't KFC
Mother's Day I don't know like what
universe I have no idea but I sit there
trying to make something funny but I
don't know what universe this is funny
yeah yeah KF d sorry ela what I'm trying
to give them some kind of benefit of the
doubt I don't know what they're thinking
it it just doesn't make any sense to me
I think this is only in a universe when
it's made by Tim and Eric yeah except
which means except I would be ironic
yeah
also the guy's a bucket of chicken was
you saying you want to eat my dick his
dicks the white meat Allah let's move on
I hate these idiots let's not talk about
them anymore so KFC in short has ruined
the HD podcast we are no longer live and
the colonel and all of his iterations
are to blame and I've no Popeyes you
heard of here Popeye stock is going up
Popeyes just got the Papa bless bump h3
bump pop-pop-pop eyes
yep speaking of which I must have
watched this video a thousand times and
I'm not exaggerating I go oh man I got
up I gotta wash this cuz I gotta get in
a good mood right now this legend he's
wearing a Teddy fresh shirt looking
pretty fresh the shirt looks good
and I don't know what he's on I mean
surely he's drunk I don't know what else
but he gave this bouncer his keys
instead of his ID and you can only
imagine how out of it
you must be they give somebody your keys
to save your ID I kept being tagged in
this because of the Teddy fresh shirt
right and I kept just like you know
ignoring it I was like yeah whatever
some guys wearing it cool but I kept
being tagging like non-stop eventually I
had to watch it and then I was blown off
I swear God watched it a hundred times
it's so beautiful so here is the bouncer
reacting to being handed keys instead of
an ID so here we go
I watched it so many times it's like I
mean it's beautiful it's like a piece of
art you couldn't put it together first
of all this line kills me every time
he's got the key up in front of camera
goes miss don't look like he's amazing
and you have to understand like how out
of Izzie this is this is basically what
this guy's looking at okay in front of a
phone very clearly recorded I don't know
what he's on but I'll take some I'll
take whatever he's having he's trying so
hard to help his boyfriend out and I
love Chaplin wherever you are man I hope
you're you're doing well dude your total
legend I got a haircut he says don't
look like you man how do you MIT even
being like blasted your mom not sure how
you mistake those but hey and then I
love how he rolls his eyes at his friend
yeah [ __ ] off Karl yeah so shout out to
Chapel and that segues me right on in to
our exciting announcement ELA today a
new teddy fresh drop came out at Teddy
fresh dot oh my god
Freddy teddy fresh calm very thrilled to
bring this to you let me just briefly
show you what we've got here mom's
sweater at you you add because you're
the designer extraordinaire so go ahead
we actually started working on this
before I was pregnant oh it's kind of
finding that now that is funny I am also
going to be a mom yes do you is it more
powerful if your mom and you wear the
mom stuff I guess but you don't need to
be a mom to wear the mom stuff you
definitely III see it as you wear it to
proclaim your love for Mom yeah
either it be them milfs or just
biological I love this shirt very fresh
since one year ago we're making fun of
all these like established in 1949 it's
always like yes 1987 what's like a dude
driving like a wagon yeah we're from one
year ago [ __ ] this is the gila client
originally shirt is so sick the school
bus so drawing from one of my
sketchbooks that it was like onto the
sketchbook when it's open it was half on
this page and half on this page so
here's the back so it's like this huge
bus that goes all the way around mm-hmm
it says a big mouth humpback can open
its mouth and swallow a gulp of water
the size of a big School Bus do it art
come on art I look this is my favorite
thing we're doing right now it's by ela
Kline what we're doing is this limited
edition t-shirt so never come back and
and it's ILA's art and we found we found
really great partners that can print
them really well and make a high quality
t-shirt so for us it's like it's a way
for her to really continue making art
and to combine our expecially fun when I
get to show stuff for my sketchbooks cuz
you guys look so so hard to present or
show like you can make an exhibition
right out of it and I have lots of
sketchbooks that are completely full
that's such a great point I think it's
such a it's a really great medium to
share your art and when you have like a
bus you can get really creative with the
medium to were you're trying to you're
trying to express how big this bus right
and it's really clever how it wraps all
the way around the side mm-hmm
that's a big opal water you know I'm
saying we finally got some reasonably
priced t-shirts 35 bucks some great
graphics man super happy inspired by the
Grateful Dead yeah we have a lot of
Grateful Dead inspired let's come out we
got some new hat colors we got some new
space diabetes we got new backpacks we
restocked all of our bags fanny packs
everything we got patches keychains it's
all happening folks this is a big one
we're super proud of it go to Ted Fisher
comm check it out Gila anything else dad
mm-hmm thank you
now here we let's let's let's cut the
[ __ ] now idubbbz
recently posted a video called fast food
power rankings I don't know if that was
called but he ranked fast food by power
rankings now at the end of his video
this is what he said he issued a
challenge he said I challenge you to
make this everyone a challenge if you
think your list is more accurate than
this then [ __ ] prove it okay
oh yeah hurt well I wasn't planning on -
but then Dan was like yo did you see
instant video I was like yeah he's like
I got huge problems with this video like
what so then we started actually
discussing it and breaking it down and I
realized that there's certainly a lot of
heat here there's certainly a spirited
conversation we had I do not know how to
use Photoshop and I just hit hit F F
that's it just hit hit it one more time
I'm so bad at Photoshop and I'm if you
hit it one more time at all take it
fullscreen hit F okay good thank you I
almost had a meltdown but that works
crisis averted
so we've put together our own power
rating chart we've got the brands on the
right we've got the power rankings on
the left s is the highest here F is
obviously garbage we should show IANS is
that gonna say the show first of all
what he must show what he did yeah I'll
pull it up here
but there was a lot of heated well here
it's basically five guys was number one
in and out Little Caesars McDonald's a
ranked chick-fil-a Papa John's Pizza
talked about Wendy's b-rank Chipotle
jack-in-the-box KFD freakin KF whoo
sorry who's that oh your mom wants some
[ __ ] KFC what thing is that to say to
mothers I know your mom wants to watch
some male strippers sorry your mom's
okay I don't get it Sonic is C calls
juniors D alone
Arby's Burger King Domino's is e and D Q
and subway earned the coveted F so we're
gonna put together our own about five
guys winning number one well I don't
have a strong opinion about five guys I
think I've only ever eaten there once so
exactly well I don't know it's okay
I just ran I remember there being a lots
of mustard on it which is not something
that I'm necessarily into but I think I
need to eat there more I don't have a
strong sense for five guys you guys feel
free to chime in but let's start doing
this let's start first of all with the F
so for me
jack-in-the-box is a clear under F is a
clear hundred-percent and unthinkable
awful everything they make is trash
what about their tacos okay let me tell
you about their tacos AK and their tacos
are diarrhea freakin deep-fried diarrhea
and a pouch Zak there's two types of
people in the world people who like
their tacos and people with class
magneti their tacos are like isn't it
like two for 99 cents bro think about
that think about that right tell me what
do you think you're actually eating when
you can get two tacos it's better than
like del Taco tacos yeah well you know
what my solid [ __ ] tastes better than my
diarrhea doesn't nobody eat either of it
so can I first get my number one choice
out of the way sure the super s ranking
super super SS
Oh should we go I think we're maybe
jumping ahead here okay we should go
bottom up maybe okay I don't want to
give away the way the goods yeah don't
come on don't spoil the ending Danis
raped the iron man we're doing a and
game review
I go to my mom after watching the movie
I go whoa there's so the ending was so
crazy
Thanos ended up a rape and she goes no
way really really no way I was like yeah
dude bounces huge purple [ __ ] Justin
gaped iron man yeah and then the colonel
came out started stripping and iron man
was doing was getting spit-roasted
that's when you take it from both sides
she was like what and they work jack and
the boss okay the Dean carefully stands
for so much yeah Mike you got there yeah
yeah go ahead dick
Wow simply be said there so Jack in the
Box is an F Dairy Queen I don't even
understand this I don't even understand
how Dairy Queen is a viable business
like they sell soft-serve ice cream
who freaking gets out of their car for
ice cream first of all I don't like and
then they also sell food Dairy Queen is
she didn't even exist as far as I can
tell that man is awful it's very quick
yeah you don't necessarily want to be a
being a queen is risky to begin with but
when you're Dairy Queen you've got
issues with that I agree
KFC obviously is the true enemy of
Island a shame because I I like their
food well listen if Papa John's is the
you know the god of h3 the colonel KFC
is say is sane he's the Antichrist the
anti Ethan I would probably put it in a
a or B if we weren't in this ela q you
understand you're promoting KFC right
I gotta be honest no I agree it's pretty
good but I hope they I hope that they
never saw another nugget as long as they
live now let me see
okay so Arby's let's move on to e Arby's
is oh that's not supposed to sit down
now Arby's is another restaurant that I
don't know how it exists
I never it's so trashy it's so white
trash it's literally a fast-food
restaurant that they serve just slabs of
like nasty roast beef between bread
that's it that's all there is to it
they're logos a giant cowboy hat it's so
trashy I don't even know what to say
about it
I don't exactly who eats at Arby's have
any of you guys eaten regularly at
Arby's once last time any of you guys
ADA Arby's
20 years ago I remember it being very
wet it was a wet burger
you got to sauce it up it was a Korean
any Arby's in your uh recent history
I do like Arby's on your list is all the
way back Beck's got Arby's and Jack and
s reading it's not the best but it's
it's good
I mean what's here what's here what
letter I put it in C mmm anyway it's
been like a decade since I've had how L
say there curly fries are good i but I
haven't eaten there in a while so I'm
gonna keep you mat F because who eats at
Arby's sorry Zack it's just that concept
of fast-food roast beef troubles me okay
now let's move it on here I don't have
any huge other problems here I've never
eaten at Sonic to be frank so one of you
guys will have to chime in on Sonic I
mean either where where is there even a
sonic I don't like the boonies like way
out I'm just gonna I'm gonna I'm not
even gonna do it here
look can I just like disappear it like
put it below and the Sonics doesn't
exist
by idiots on ik okay I do like Sonic the
Hedgehog can I bring it back okay now
let's move it on to D now Oh Burger King
is actually e for me Burger King is
literally a poor man's McDonald's
there's nothing good there's no reason
to go to Burger King when I grew up
there was a McDonald's in a Burger King
right next to each other in Ventura and
you literally only went to Burger King
when the McDonald's drive-through was
too long they there I do not like Burger
King the burgers are a nightmare I agree
they changed their french fry recipe a
long time ago I guess to distinguish
themselves from McDonald's and it's not
as good Burger King
sorry I'll go to you after Arby's I
think that's accurate
now chick-fil-a I've eaten there a
couple of times I'm gonna I'm gonna go
chick-fil-a mother-effing got him oh
mighty chick-fil-a from ezd and I'll
tell you why I went there that's gonna
be a big controversy right there I feel
that's the most controversial so
chick-fil-a for me we ate there once in
Agoura it's just it was bread it was
fried chicken and I wasn't impressed it
just did not do it for me sorry sorry
sorry guys
I was more familiar I don't even
remember it Wendy's is pretty bomb I'm
gonna give them a see I like their
smoothies I like their square burgers I
like everything she's going on well I'm
gonna chime in on the ones that I know
now Ian had an interesting take on
Subway he's like the only reason you go
okay this thing's driving me crazy let
me just because you can lock it in there
one more
Ian had an interesting take on Subway
wait but you're gonna you gotta cover
that little that basically the only
reason to go to some ways if you're too
lazy to make yourself a sandwich because
the sandwich you make it home it's gonna
be know just as good okay that's a good
point but isn't when she say that about
every fast-food um that's a that's an
interesting insight as well kind of you
where did he put subway subway he gave a
F yeah he put all the way
now I'm gonna I'm I kind of get his
point because we're somewhere here
here's what you've noted about Subway
that I think is fascinating now I have
every sandwich you make tastes the same
in a weird way
which is kind of so I get his point it's
like you wanna you want a roast beef
you want a Philly cheese that you want
to meet it's all taste the same
I hate subway and you know that but it's
at least a B or C and spare the day back
in the box
I person it's a pretty good option when
exact something it's not too bad for you
you can eat a sandwich that's now you're
getting fired up not gonna kill you yeah
I wish I knew more about that ones so
it's so subway for me
Subway's been there for me you know
those five-dollar footlongs when I was
in college got me through some got me
food when I was broke not even just even
just when we moved out here and we were
still kind of broke I gotta give subway
a seat a solid C honestly because it's a
greater burden for a quick relatively
healthy meal and I got a I kind of got
to give it up to subway and I hate
someone and you can just have them
stacking onto like I'll get a sandwich
and I'll be like I want every mother
effing agree
I want lettuce I want tomato and one
onion I want spinach I want red pepper
I'm a black of on pepper Cheney I want
jalapeno salt and pepper
mani and they don't even [ __ ] Seder in
the bad and I because they probably see
the weirdest [ __ ] those Subway sandwich
makers very nice sometimes but you think
they better I mean they're like
absolutely when I order out wash your
face to about like day I dare you to say
something cuz I don't get cheese you
know so I I balance it out but also
that's what I like my same age point for
me is that you can eat there and you
don't have to meet because I I'm not
vegetarian but I don't love meat and a
lot of times my choice would be to go
without me
but like at Arby's I don't even know if
not an option Barbies no are nobody
cheetah Arby's that's not good like that
earring Oh
because they have good curly fries now
Domino's I I think every time I've had
Domino's it's fairly good that's pretty
good but honestly I'm gonna give dumb as
a seat yeah I can't hate like I've had a
lot of local pizza that is awful
like you really roll the dice when you
call in pizza from these like local
businesses and don't get me wrong I love
all pizzas but Domino's has been
consistently good
every time I've ordered it so I'm not
gonna hit on Thomas I'm gonna give us
see now Chipotle I have a love-hate
relationship with Chipotle yeah where do
you put that that's a tough one I gotta
think like I think I think Chipotle is
gonna get a seat for me and I was gonna
say be really put it right in between
what do you think then we'll see what
you said about Subway about everything
in Subway no matter what you get tastes
the same that's how I feel about your
Pope it's ok meal but like you're gonna
get [ __ ] sick of it that's all they
got I hate it too sometimes I always get
diarrhea always and I'm not saying that
cuz it's like a meme like I literally
always get diarrhea but it works for me
and I love I love the guac scoops yeah I
love the cheese love sour cream and same
thing you don't have to eat meat you can
make it ball with like rice or anything
got some veggies veggies and guac yeah
and it tastes exactly the same as if you
got the means yeah like when I'm in the
mood for Chipotle it's great but it's
OneNote it gives you diarrhea but all of
these are one knows wrong wrong gila
subway and Chipotle have that
distinctively in common yeah yeah I
agree I would still pick they're now
multi percentage now we're getting
interesting now little seizures is a I
still never they're little seizures I
mean for five bucks you can get a pie
that's pretty good I cannot hate on
little seizures and I'm gonna once again
give this I know this is very
interesting because I'm giving this a
see as well see that's why I feel like
Chipotle and subway or maybe you think
they're hiked here I got above and um
you know what I'm gonna I think you're
right yeah
because it's consistent you know you're
getting
it's relatively healthy I'm gonna I'm
gonna go ahead and cuz little seizures
the best I can say for that is like for
five dollars you get a pretty decent pie
no yeah good call
now talk okay so McDonald's I gotta tell
you yes where are you coming down so Ian
made a great point he put McDonald's
eight here and I have to say he was he
made a compelling argument
McDonald's is so consistent it is so
timeless everything on that menu is
refined polished the quality control is
excellent I almost am never disappointed
from when I order McDonald's was a
hamburger
whether it's breakfast whether it's a
coffee whether it's french fries I'm
always getting what I want and I know
this is sounds strange to but their soda
pops are on point like they mix the
syrup and the ice levels are like I'm so
satisfied when I get a Coke or a soda
pop they're more than any other
restaurant and I I have to give them
credit for that I couldn't agree more
and so a McDonald's is a tear bro
there's a reason why they sold a
trillion hamburgers coffee's great yeah
we yes we drink the conference's
hashbrown the Egg McMuffin Egg McMuffin
Donald's breakfast is legit wouldn't
know me but still bomb the Akaka Cola
syrup they give to McDonald's is
different than what you can buy in the
like groceries oh man that's what a
Goliath they're they have their own
recipe and it tastes great I love the
recipe totally I'm afraid that we are
passing the break oh [ __ ] hello we got
to take a break guys we'll be right back
admit it you think that cybercrime is
something that happens to other people
you may think that no one wants your
data or the hackers can't grab your
password or credit card details but you
are wrong stealing data from
unsuspecting people on public Wi-Fi is
one of the simplest and cheapest ways
for hackers to make money and when you
leave your internet connection
unencrypted you might as well be writing
a password and credit card number on a
huge billboard for the rest of the world
to see that's why I decided to take
action to protect myself from cyber
security I use Express vpm expressvpn
secures and minimizes your internet
browser by encrypting your data and
hiding your public IP address expressvpn
has easy to use apps and runs seamlessly
in the background of your computer phone
and tablet turning on expressvpn
protection only takes one click using
expressvpn I can safely surf on public
Wi-Fi without being snooped on or having
my personal data stolen and for less
than seven dollars a month you get the
same expressvpn protection that I use
myself expressvpn is rated number one
VPN service by TechRadar and comes with
a 30-day money-back guarantee
so what the heck are you waiting for
it's a no-brainer and it's a no-lose
with that money-back guarantee protect
your online activity right now today I
find out how you can get three months
for free and expressvpn comm / h3 that's
e FP r e SS VPN dot-com / h3 for 3
months free with a one-year package
visit expressvpn comm / h3 to learn more
what you are looking at here is a
technological marvel it may look like a
simple toothbrush to you but it is so
much more than what meets the eye let me
introduce you to quip the toothbrush
that is changing the frickin game
because let's face it your breath stinks
your teeth are nasty and you need to get
your [ __ ] together because oral hygiene
is probably the most important thing
when it comes to dating respecting
yourself and overall looking good
there's nothing worse than a stinky
mouth let me tell you about quit this is
the only toothbrush that I would grace
my beautiful clean mouth with it's got
first of all soft bristles that would
never damage your gums that's number one
okay number two it vibrates ask any
dentist they're gonna tell you you want
a vibrating toothbrush it's the only way
to clean your mouth and number three it
pulsates every minute to tell you when
it's time to switch sides and when
you're done brushing it'll turn off so
the minute times you and make sure
you're getting that dentist recommended
brush time in quip is a beautiful slick
unbelievable product it starts at only
$25 and you can get signed up for a free
refill pack and they're gonna send you
ahead to replace you just pop it on and
you're good to go
that's why I love quip I would not stick
another brush in my mouth you think I'm
blowing smoke up your ass try this try
it and I'm telling you your mouth you
gonna be coming out squeaky clean okay
that's why I love quip that's why
they're back to a twenty thousand dental
professionals quip starts at just $25
and if you go to get clipped comm /h do
right now you get your first rebuilt
refill pack for free with equipment let
your toothless so get your free real
refill pack free at GE t qi p comm / h3
get quick comm / h3 right the [ __ ] now
and we are back so we had just place
McDonald's at an a-rank
now talk about let's move on and talk
about now Ian made an excellent point
about to talk about as well hmm
he said of talkable and I totally agree
it's in a class of its own
there's nobody on here who can compete
with Taco Bell that does we'll talk
about does fast Mexican food and they've
managed to succeed they've got all this
crazy [ __ ] they're slinging food we just
had talked about yesterday
it was okay mm-hmm now Dan you feel
strongly about this I know this is this
is basically what prompted this because
yeah Ian have given it what like a see
here I have his tier list yeah no well
he had it a B yet it a B so what you
gonna hit on that it's [ __ ] [ __ ] man
oh it's a bi it's not that good in fact
in fact not above B in fact the only
reason it gets a B is because of the
uniqueness of it yeah that is your fast
food Mexican I always wish that there
was a an equivalent of Chipotle we'd
Drive Thru right yeah yeah I don't know
what fully does not drive through they
make that [ __ ] quit man no drive-through
Chipotle now okay so there you have it
there's nothing really more to say about
Taco Bell in and out so this is a tough
because you know that everyone here on
the west coast is crazy about in and out
strong feelings and I am and I how also
have strong feelings about I don't know
let me tell you the burgers the the
patty is very small but the quality the
flavor the experience is fantastic
here's where my problems begin the
french fries and anyone who says
otherwise are absolute ass and i know
they're trying hard to be like fresh and
organic they chopped up the french fries
in the store you can see them pressing
up they throw them right in the deep
fryer but that's just not how you make
good french fries there's a process you
gotta soak it in cold wire you got to
get the bleach out and you got to freeze
it in some cases they they don't I'm not
making a joke dan this is an art if you
freeze it it's gonna bleach oh oh - get
the bleep yes yeah
the starch I thought you were sorry you
got to get some bleach out of the
cupboard the bleach I just misspoke I
wish I was as funny as you thought I was
so so again I love the burgers and the
price point is unbelievable you can go
so just day and age you can get a burger
fries and a drink for like six bucks
yeah when I was a kid McDonald's oh yeah
when I was a kid I go to McDonald's and
you could get a value meal for five
bucks and that's what I remember it was
so beautiful with such a whole number
like here's I got a fiber I get lunch
today and out has maintained that
through the years so that's a huge
accomplishment the French fries hold it
back I'm getting it at a rank I have a
question for you
between McDonald's and they're not which
burger do you like better I think
they're very different in and out I
think technically is better remain in
and out is like real food mmm McDonald's
is like I mean it's trash but it's bomb
also I like McDonald's better Wow you
know what like I don't know man
McDonald's it you got to you got to
appreciate McDonald's for what it is I
can really get down with the McDonald's
burger mm-hmm
but I think technically speaking in and
out is a better burger if that makes any
sense okay
noisy Mike's Jersey Mike's it's just
stupid Sam at Subway no I'll tell you
wow Jersey Mike's there's a bunch of
Amiens of Subway though you know that
Jersey ranks done like a snobbish subway
and their shits and I even that much
better they just put a ton of lettuce
and they fold the meat I hate how they
fold the meat Zach's about to quit right
now by that he's back here it's freshly
like sliced their Subway's not even real
turkey or real freshly sliced who cares
they send you a [ __ ] visit not about
real food yeah I just don't I just don't
like the whole I get it
their sandwiches are even more
repetitive in a way than Subway's it's
all sliced lettuce and it's all folded
me do me
subway wins yeah there's always been a
subway next to where we leave no matter
where we do right anywhere in the
country there's gonna be a subway within
like 10 feet of where you live because
there on every corner now five guys I
don't have a pinion about because I'm a
kind of boolean there once so I'm gonna
remove them sorry well I think it could
definitely go as a see I just don't know
enough and I don't want to we had it in
New York a couple of times but now don't
what is this one it's all right Pizza
I'm not super familiar with pizza
probably is probably a CPA - it's lower
than Domino's yeah I think it's D okay I
think that's fair now Carl's jr. I this
used to be my jam and every day the
crisps cut fries dipped in ranch is
heavenly
it's godly it's insane the burger
sometimes it's awful sometimes it's bomb
there's not a lot of consistency but
sometimes it's the best sometimes it's
the worst the tough call with Carl's jr.
because of the ups and downs I get but
I'm gonna give it a seat I think that's
fair it's like you it's if McDonald's
you always know what you're gonna get
Carl's is definitely a gamble sometimes
it's D worse if someone that has a
vegetarian yeah they recently started
serving the beyond burger and I tried it
out I was pretty good it was pretty good
so far the s-rank is completely empty
we have Papa John's and we've got Shake
Shack now let me go on to Papa John's
you guys know you guys know the meme the
Papa John mean you know how I feel I
mean you know the joke but do how do you
how do I really feel about me yeah now
Papa John's to me the butter sauce is
bomb as [ __ ] mm-hmm you dip it you pour
it you do whatever you want it's so good
now a lot of people are gonna say Papa
John's pizzas not that good and I
actually think it's fantastic every time
I order it
I know started as a joke but every time
I order Papa John's I genuinely love the
pizza that I get it's consistent it's
great it's fresh better ingredients
Papa will live forever I give I think
it's sucks
I give Papa John's in a I like Papa John
I like to me I would give it
d- maybe i'm right there with the eleven
hundred percent over rated
i don't know i just don't really like
the pizza I guess if we even and out
then we're gonna have to give it a B and
every single time you talk to anybody
about pop you know what Papa does the
sauce and it's like the sauces and the
pizza man you're right you know what
Papa John's is not as good as McDonald's
it and out which are tried and true you
know what pop I think Papa John's is is
a B for me yeah
now finally Shake Shack first of all
there's a burger chain that we
discovered in New York people have
likened it to the in and out of the East
Coast because it's such an institution
recently Shake Shack has come to the
west coast
there's several here in LA there's some
in Las Vegas it's pretty much gone all
over the nation L now Shake Shack is
owned by a by like a gourmet chef who
it's a little pricey but they use this
incredible quality of meat and they
smash the burger it's a smash burger on
top of the burger it's super greasy
little dumpling like the bread is so
soft and so cloudy and like unbelievable
it's super greasy that's one negative
thing I would say cuz when you hold it
it's like it's so deadly but it's it's
delicious it's on it's unparalleled in
the flavor mm-hmm on top of that on top
of these beautiful the burger that's
just it's the best-tasting burger ever a
little greasy I'll top that they have
the best french fries period they've got
these critics crying how do you call it
it's like the cut crinkle crinkle Thank
You Zac they got these crinkle-cut
french fries that are perfectly seasoned
and cooked and on top of that you can
get this nacho cheese dip not an
ostrich's as a cheese dip that is
absolutely to die for
and you will die if you eat Shake Shack
for me is the only undisputed it's the
only one deserving of the true s class
and if you have the opportunity to eat
at Shake Shack I cannot recommend it to
you enough go try Shake Shack get a
cheeseburger french fries and cheese
sauce and we are
unbelievable and you didn't even rate
Shake Shack you think if I don't think
he's been there he tried it it would
bump five guys I think it's the best
tasting burger out of all the burgers
I've ever had again I can't comment on
five guys but I think Ian would love
shakes I mean anyone would it's in New
York there's a line every day it's fast
food doesn't take that long get your
food but there's such so many people
that want it there's a there's like a
30-minute line it's that good the people
are waiting queuing up for Shake Shack
it's phenomenal it's incredible they
have chicken sandwiches that are on
another level it's just simply the best
have any of you what do you guys think
RS and chime in here
have you had Shake Shack by the way I
have not it sounded like Zach had you
bet I have yeah but I think he got put
in and out in the ass the S category you
would bump in and out yeah and and Ian
and Dan well you know where I stand on
talkable that's a clear s for me the
rest the rest I'm I'm pretty on board
with your ratings here dan look are you
gonna get stock labelled an ass like I
know that you're vegetarian and you like
it cuz you can eat there but like let's
be honest let's be honest with each
other here you know in your heart Taco
Bell is not an S I stand I stand for the
Bell the only my only worry here is is
it fair that we put Shake Shack above of
McDonald's that's what I'm wondering I
do think so but I do like the gonna pay
if I have to say which burger is the
best Shake Shack look I got an a that's
a good rating again I am heard from me
and why are you so quiet in what's going
on with you oh I'm taking it all in
I don't think gonna have an S mm-hmm I
you wouldn't rate any of these s no hmm
they all have negatives yeah and as I
make it it's all relatives it's not
listed but round Table Pizza bake-off is
Mike the segments over round Table Pizza
here trying to have a show here yes
[Laughter]
I'll turn it back on because this part
is that the next part is Ian's report
Ian went to Coachella over the last
weekend why don't you come on in here
actually in join us yeah you're all swap
over to Ian what to Coachella because he
heard that Kanye was doing his Sunday
service there and he immediately bought
a ticket and went there on his own by
himself I don't go to the movies by
myself let alone to Coachella this guy's
insane for fun yet
that's pretty scary I'm going to
Coachella by yourself yeah I want to
hear about it so in you want to sit here
you can control the out kill him okay so
first of all tell me how did you come to
Coachella tell me the the lead-up I was
in my car I was at the gym and I was in
I was on my phone in between things and
then I saw that Kim announced that Kanye
was going to be there and I sprinted out
of the gym like that minute and ran to
my car grabbed my card and bought it in
the parking lot so I was like I gotta go
when do you buy exactly it's a Coachella
like we can take it yeah you can't buy
singles you have to buy a full three-day
was a ticket it was like well the fees
kill you the fees are so crazy so that
added like an extra hundred bucks but it
was like our feet yeah kind of feeling
that listed on StubHub it like 350 but
then the fees put up like 460 what the
hell kind of [ __ ] fees is that so
that's our original - you didn't get her
aftermarket ticket did you
well that was they had it listed as 360
it was aftermarket though oh stop hub
took so so much money from them now in
I've never been a fan of anything in my
life quite like you are with Kanye you
genuinely tend to be towards the fandom
spectrum right like you're a fan of
things not like to this level I don't
like anything that
much usually your phone.i oh I like
things I do like that you're a man who
likes well you yeah like you stuff your
big I like that no not like that I don't
think most people are like yeah this
much but you know but but Connie does
have a I'm gonna say cult for lack of a
better word he does have a strong
central fan base yeah so you're not the
only one who's being allured by whatever
magnetism he has no there's a bunch yeah
there's a lot out there and so you went
there by yourself
yeah on Friday after our show hmm and
did you immediately make friends what
was the well yeah we shouldn't like I
met people pretty quick yeah I didn't
take long because I don't know
everyone's just there to have fun and
have a good time and right I think there
are a lot of people that go alone to
meeting people and did anyone recognize
you know I had a bandana over my face to
like most the time cuz the dust is so
bad right
are you hoping someone would recognize
you no a little bit I'm good I was
famous in the Kanye community not enough
I guess but ya know did you have to
build a tent yeah actually it was awful
because the winds there so crazy and
someone's well the first night my tent
came undone and I slammed into my
neighbor's tent while you were sleeping
in it yeah I was on the planet wire girl
those girls nice that's a great opener
okay just smash the [ __ ] out of your
tent what are you doing tomorrow didn't
go anywhere this is like at 3:00 a.m.
yeah they were like please get away from
there did you hit him up the next day no
I didn't see them actually again did you
say everybody's different and did you
see what they looked like though in the
middle of the night no you didn't even
get to see if they were like no so I was
so embarrassed by that but then the next
night my other neighbors tent slammed
into mine so the pecking order every
time I'd go to the campsite at night
there would be like shredded tents all
of it sounds a little fire festival yeah
it was kind of the wind was so bad
actually in one of the
tense or one of those stages the wind
was so bad as this big outdoor stage and
they have this huge overhang and it was
shaking so much people around me were
leaving because they were nervous I
would fall down and something actually
fell and landed on this girl and she
wants the hospital oh my I don't know
what happened with her actually and how
close was that to your tent
well that was at one of the stages that
was and did you ever consider leaving as
a because the one was no never I was it
was that kid cudi Kanye was gonna come
out what happens so do you have like
public showers yeah shower yeah there I
was there and and what do you eat that's
the problem they have a bad awful it's
like junk a lot so much junk food and
things like that so they sell food there
yeah but it's so overpriced it's like
it's like $15 a slice of pizza
Oh miss fees $15 slice of pizza
sounds like my perf and and what did you
eat though I mean I
pizza' how was the pizza it was it was
okay but how would you rank it all over
yeah it's a dt r yeah yeah so you guys
have gone to music festival right I mean
for a video but it was kind of like
behind what was it overnight either age
yeah we popped in for an hour yeah yeah
that's it's an ordeal okay and what do
you live in your intent like I won there
by your stuff do you
I kind of would hide it in my tent under
like dirty clothes and stuff the valley
enough on everything dirty
interesting strategy the Hydra by those
in 30 I yeah I dare you to take this
yeah cuz no one I mean hopefully not
digging through there nope
so here's the pictures we'll start here
yeah you went primarily for a Kanye
Sunday service yeah so that doors open
at 6:00 and so I got up at 5:00 and
gotten lined by like 5:20 this seems
like a large crowd yeah so these are
pictures I took so I waited for hours
but I got I'm basically at the front so
are you against the railing in the front
was one person in front of me and I know
all those you could have elbowed your
way up there though okay well the
problem is that a free-for-all I mean
yeah you could have but no it's always
positive vibe yeah right you be I'd be
throwing elbows buzz wait four hours
well you kind of had a choice where it
was actually when the doors opened the
line just called it collapsed the woman
just kind of went they had to hold us
back and she was like everyone please
walk we are now letting people in and
then immediately everyone started
sprinting oh my god so they say oh yeah
that's a whole giant field they like let
in at the same time we're just run yeah
did you sprint I was free are you with
other people thank God the guys next to
me I was talking to but then we split up
because some of us will you basically
sprinted off by yourself
everyone was yeah everybody flat out run
what a scene yeah they're games yeah
well because there was one way was the
hill and then the other way was the
merch tent so you had to decide what
you're okay I went to the merch you got
the merch on
oh because is it limited yeah I wish our
merch was that hot okay and then after
like Teddy fresh calm after like 20
minutes the merch line was like hundreds
of people long so so you did you picked
right yeah I went there and then got the
hill and I was pretty much now how much
you're wearing one of the merch prunex
right now how much was that 160 what did
you spend in all right
I spent a lot of money spent like a
thousand bucks I said yeah yeah but I
don't I don't go any I haven't gone on
vacation in like five years no you're I
know yeah this was like once I was there
I was like okay I will get a slice of
pizza I will I'm gonna treat myself yeah
I'm gonna have fun I don't do that off
that's Coachella I'm gonna treat myself
and eat one slice leads into one slice
of pizza and so this was 160 you got two
of them one for a resale right just in
case yeah or if my brother wants it yeah
and what do you what are those reselling
for I saw a few like 350 300 Wow so yeah
I actually saw a picture is it not here
I saw a picture of somebody selling
grass
yeah it is in there it's oh it's in your
thing oh yeah yeah I saw someone
actually sold successfully on eBay a
clump of grass yeah so they do you think
- you didn't think - I didn't think
about the grass I blew it actually some
people even selling bags of air that is
funny that's so yeah those are those are
in that folder the pictures of my germs
coffin a bag
yeah so in you went from the merch but
then you kind of did that must have had
the elbow your way to the front if you
went to the merged first not really cuz
it like a since I got there so early it
was fine I was able to do it and while
you were in line were you strategizing
like should I cover the gate or should
go to the merch I was figuring yeah are
you mind was raced all day and what were
the what were the options that you
weighed what we what were the pros and
cons with the merch for you well the
merch I went well if I get a couple of
these and it helps pay for this crazy
amount I've been spending on pizza I'll
feel a little better mentally fret for
this for the show right so it was an
investment investment run was there
people at the merch booth buying like
tons of yeah yes there's but there was a
guy next to him like three grand Wow
yeah how many bags you have you should
rob his ass yeah these guys are walking
around he well cuz they were selling
socks for 50 bucks
mm-hmm and so he bought like 10 pairs of
those socks and I was like Jesus dude no
making money from it right yeah probably
I'm surprised it on the limit on show
you it was lit it was 800 he maxed it
out but still I mean that adds up fast
oh yeah eggs
I saw the merch it was pricey but yeah
there were people big handfuls to show
you classic go to just do that so Oh God
not like this so let's continue you can
tell me what we're looking at here
that's really cool yeah well yeah it was
sexy right yeah I took a panorama photos
part we got a video yeah so here is when
they so how did they enter into the
field because it's surrounded 360
behind there's the gate that on one side
of the hill was all VIP they came in
through there oh I see that's where all
the like sober celebrities in people
so they had like a they had like a
30-piece band or something and they had
like like 30 people choir that we
circled around the hill and then they
had like up maybe a hundred backup
dancers - and where was Kanye in the and
he was very laid back he wasn't he
didn't really take center stage that
much he only actually wrapped two songs
mmm the whole thing was it was about
three hours long three hours yeah so his
his involvement was quite minimal by
this yeah he was kind of like laying low
he was doing you know his he was
sampling on his machine and things like
that but he was letting the choir and
the band and all that be the main thing
and so what was his contribution did he
arrange these whoa yeah and like it
would be like a church like a gospel
song and then a Kanye song in that
gospel style and then song again so the
whole things are weaving in and out
non-stop so let's have a listen let's
see what would ya
[Applause]
you hear that it's the sound of our
video being claimed that your hand
that's my hand press it out but hand
reaching out for thing so to come bless
me where did you have a religious man
trance here because it is I mean it is a
prayer service yeah yeah it was a did
you find Jesus yeah I'm a Christian no
no no I it was that what was interesting
about it I'm holding him lightsaber
looks like a camera not a lightsaber
damn cool it's like a it's like a little
oh yeah but what was interesting was I
don't think a lot of people were quite
understanding what it was going to be
mm-hmm they were expecting a concert
like it's just a Kanye show it's so like
at the start they come out and they
start bringing up Jesus and lifting your
heart to Jesus and and I could tell the
people around me were kind of like this
isn't really my thing everyone sings say
praise Jesus and the people around me
were a little nervous by the third hour
everyone was doing but they were all
everyone was on board yeah yeah yeah did
you feel that your are you religious man
no you feel the Spirit of Christ on that
day I felt like I it was like that
something in the air and the whole thing
electric that valuable air I should have
backed know there was something kind of
spiritual about it definitely I mean all
those people doing that at the same time
there was over 50,000 people there Wow
so like doing what at the same time just
all being in the trying to like sing
these songs and talk about like
religious ideas and things like that I
mean over 50,000 in one place all doing
that it's hard not to be like this is
kind of like a powerful thing going on
so it was I mean I told that I cried
what moment did you cry dude what was it
that at that moment there was a moment
or a chance there
Burke came out and then he did his verse
on this song and one of my favorite
songs of Kanye's called ultralight beam
and it's really like an emotional slow
song and then DMX came out and started
delivering this prayer about like
believing in yourself and over don't
ruin this like your DMX government mr.
Burton's big DMX man like believing in
yourself and overcoming adversity and
things like that and DMX has had so many
issues in the past he hasn't been
arrested many times has a lot of
problems with drugs and things like that
but he's doing really good now
mm-hmm so hearing that and seeing him
like doing so well and all these people
and I was just smiling so hard and then
I was like oh my god I'm like I'm like
crying I'd like tears streaming down my
mind it just from the whole thing there
was just so much so that was like a
moment I was an experienced am what a
moment yeah here's another clip let's
watch here yeah so these are the backup
dancers you mentioned yeah so they were
just kind of doing things your whole
time they've got a kind of a Bhagwan bye
with all the same outfits and took over
the whole state of Utah or something
throw it up yeah were you throwing it up
oh no I was into it the whole time would
can I get you possibly wearing one of
these purple dentist's assistant outfits
yeah I'm sure those are probably pretty
pricey but I mean there was a version
like that like 250 yeah so the whole
time this is what the stream looked like
but people are watching it at home I
don't know the keyhole yeah and I really
don't get it
is he just trying to there's a chance I
wonder if he's just trying to make the
experience more special for the people
that were there live yeah maybe because
it doesn't really do justice to it and
were you able to see Kanye and everyone
up on the top of the hill yeah that's
cool
yeah I saw him a lot so it was it was a
and in the back here Mike because you
you are kind of a Kanye groupie you
follow him everywhere he goes are you
hoping that do you have some kind of
fantasy where he recognizes you and he
goes hey yeah I've heard about you I've
seen you around must have some kind of
fantasy like that right no not really
really actually I kind of like I mean I
I like the music I like what he's doing
and I I think things like this are great
and all that but if I if I met him I
feel I could kind of mess it would be
weird but you would but if he reached
out was like in I mean yeah yeah sure
yeah but you know I'm content I'm very
fine just like and do you fantasize
about being recognized within the Kanye
community like what like what are your
fantasies are you is it a happy but I do
wonder like if there's a ticket for you
in here somewhere like what is it what
do you mean just well you you follow
them everywhere you're part of this
community would it be nice to find do
you fantasize about being like a leader
of this Kanye community of some sorts or
being recognized for your insights and
devotion not really I mean I just I just
really like it it's not a thing that I'm
like oh I got to figure out how to
monetize not monetize most you know
being recognized for your devotion do
you know what I mean EULA you look at me
like you know I'm just wondering you
know how would that be like what
well mostly being you know Kanye bi I
feel like Kanye being like it's an
ultimate right I mean it'd be cool to
yeah I guess I guess that's true I have
we got another video here so there I
could see him on this one
and that guy singing right there him his
name's ant Clemens he was the one I was
in his music video recently Oh for real
yeah the ones singing there oh so that's
what it looked like yeah oh this is the
VIP look at these knobs yeah yeah so
that's kind of how they would come enter
and exit behind it sick
but yeah so I I can whoa wow that looks
awesome
yeah I mean it was like so hold on so
they made this on the VIP so there's no
there's not even any like railing or
anything on the VIP side they're just
politely standing at the foot of the
hill yeah it's probably people didn't
they know and yeah over there did you
see anyone interesting on the VAP side I
mean I saw Kim Kim walk by that's cool
would you scream her name no I I didn't
but I I and then I saw pictures of some
other celebrities oh so where were you
in this picture prop smile if you go to
the blast one you can kind of I can spot
myself Oh for real okay there's me is
that before after after though you went
in all white
yeah I thought be funny yeah oh here it
is Kanye West Sunday service grass $65
and I think it's sold 400 bucks right
yeah if you go the next one
I don't know how holy it is just taking
clumps of grass out of the field
I hate we're here to make money right
one bid that was me it wasn't well no
the house my god the father he bought it
hundred that was you that was me air
from Kanye's show
60,000 uh tone it down so where's the
one with you in it because I didn't oh
wait no go back a few pictures back back
yeah that one like if you were too crazy
zoom in you could spot me but it well
were you approximately in this photo
like somewhere I was like right against
the railing like right a little to the
right there right around there
no so
uh yeah it was crazy I mean this is
their first the first performance coach
Hill has ever done the morning oh and
they've never I mean this is so uniquely
mm-hmm nothing like this I feel like it
could happen again
so you you were there at a special
moment special time
oh gosh to prove it you breathe the air
you don't need to bag it you stood on
the grass you don't need to clump it you
were there I'm very glad I went
and one day Kanye is gonna notice you
someday some dope also you were visiting
Arianna oh that was a separate yeah that
was later that night you were so close
how did you get so closer in I elbowed
some some teenage girls sniffer farts
from this distance I mean that's one way
to look at it I suppose uh you got to be
super dedicated to get that close
because Arianna she was like the main
thing I heard you got like a million
bucks
how the hell did you get this close you
that's like Oh third thing tell me did
you just really elbow your way all the
way up no no I I went I stayed at that
stage for a few hours watched the other
people and nobody care about and then
when they would when fans of that person
would leave I feel closer and then
eventually I got there did you ever have
problems waiting up from where he had to
pee no really I was worried about that
but no I would make sure I'd go before
and because we saw the Chili Peppers
will our speech that someone Israel once
and I tried to get up like close to the
stage and I had to pee and I was just I
had to pee I was so miserable but there
you go you're young man your prostate
isn't yet yeah I think I was drinking
alcohol - that'll do it so um Arianna
you're a big fan of yeah nothing like
Kanye no but I see I was second most
excited to see her I really liked her
this is the third time I've seen her so
have you I met her at the Kanye I think
Kid Cudi right right yeah yeah she's
awesome she's back yeah yeah the nicest
person was it was blew my mind
have you ever beat off at the thought of
being with Ariana
I've never beat off no don't have you
I'm telling you the trend I'm a man of
God
not yet now but before you met her did
you beat officer Ariana
there is no before yeah after I'm a dog
and it's fine if you have broke up with
Pizza Davidson Davidson yeah I don't
like to see anybody suffer you know that
good and we've done no let me see here
dude this is crazy they got so close
yeah I think one of the next
who's the guy she's giving the lap dance
to just one of her dancers if you go
right now I'd be surprised if you
weren't beating off right now to be
honest to be pretty sexual you know that
guy went home and beat off or the yeah
yeah I was I was right there did she
ever look at you yeah oh you made eye
contact but I wonder if she remembered
you because she makes I don't think she
would here's a guy that bro you
definitely be it off this night in your
town look at this I was losing my mind
but why you like the one guy with near a
million girls no there are a lot of guys
there yeah yeah I feel like I feel like
at that level of super fandom that it's
it's probably mixed yeah I know ever I
think I did pretty well cuz I met a few
people that oh and she brought Justin
Bieber so he was oh wow yeah I saw
Justin at post show backstage I think I
think he's a nice guy on a side I like
just to be at least she's evolved and
matured a lot in the past like several
years yeah yeah how come I wonder how
come Biebs and Ariana never got it on
well he's married no yeah oh yeah that
was someone threw a lemon at her I got a
pic oh my god we gotta sell this to TMZ
matter it's like so good dumb
tell me cuz well Beyonce headline last
year uh what everyone called it like Bey
chela and all this stuff and she has an
album called lemonade yeah so some crazy
Beyonce fan went and threw a lemon at
her
for trying for because for being offered
yeah I guess what a psycho yeah [ __ ] I
really yeah is so I hope she was ejected
up she was arrested for assault
yeah hit her in there and then it like
the one of the dancers stepped on it and
a girl's clothes that I'm clean licked
stage did they throw it hard at her
didn't hit her that with our but yeah
and did those security catch the go
through it I have no idea you should
have beat her ass when I mean besides I
think right it looks like the lemon is
how did you capture that yeah wait how
did you capture that was that from a
video yeah I took this is rare I have
you seen pictures of this on the
internet not like that that's wrong I'm
kidding you should license like that's a
valuable photo I I could totally see
that on the front of like these kind of
you know gossip yeah I just some of
these crazy fans stand that's the word
psycho look nuts whole thing about also
that people thought that they didn't get
paid the same but then they didn't heard
yeah is what I read oh I wasn't
I didn't clarify actually I'm not sure
they both got paid the same eight
million and I guess Beyonce fans were
upset why is it okay I think they
thought at first that Ariana got paid
more
I thought I heard yeah well I hate to
tell you Beyonce fans but your girdles
been around a while I'm not saying she's
I mean I mean she's falling out and
she's not that but she's been around
forever the Beyonce fans okay you don't
care about I'm saying she's not what can
I do she's not in vogue as much she's
popular no I don't think it they even
need to compare them she was last year
and this year it's Ariana but why is
everyone asking she's the only female
artist that's allowed to have success no
I think her friends are just crazy I
don't know in the lemon yeah some of
these fans are just I mean cuz at the
same time Ariana Grande's fans like
would go into Pete Davidson's Instagram
comments and tell him to kill himself
and he had to be hospitalized
why were they selling him to kill him
what did he do because they broke up
never even like that they were dating
well they were getting [ __ ] even just
for dating her and then they had a
little like you know some tension after
their breakup and then her fans were
like going there and telling him to kill
himself and stuff these just know right
they had a little beef yeah yeah now do
you fear that you a Kanye fans on the
other hand very nice pastor I was going
we don't do this no but do you fear that
maybe you are a Stan of Kanye oh I am
yeah and do you fall into the same kind
of pit do you do are you aware that
maybe you fall into the same I really
believe that his his diehard fans like
that or I've only seen them pretty much
be nice but it's cuz they're always on
the defensive right because everyone
else hates Connor he's always getting
[ __ ] on the desert Kanye PR warriors
yeah so I think because of that the
diehard fans are way more open and nice
to everyone because they're just trying
to say like no he's good is there anyone
you hate as a result of being a Kanye
stand is there enemies of Kanye there
were the enemies well I don't know like
the people on his subreddit hate like
Drake and stuff are you - hey Drake know
your fan adrik yeah I like him I know
that's controversy if you saw Drake on
the street what would you do I mean I
wouldn't yeah but you know I don't know
the noni did to hate anyone you know
it's all just well the biggest takeaway
for me is that you beat off to the
thought of Arianna and we don't you know
totally you met her face to face you
sorry no well doesn't happen I respect
ariana grande very much not about
respecting big band and I don't do that
I just everyone go to church all right
and and thank you for the Coachella
report that you took pictures you had a
really just experience yes you had a you
you went you did your thing I admire the
fact that you it's very fun you know
what I should I should back up
in this world is people are nihilistic
and they don't care about anything and
that's the cool thing I respect and I
appreciate that you are willing to like
things that you are willing to put
yourself out there to go to Coachella by
yourself pitch a tent in the wind to
show love and have a good time that's
something I would never do and I think
it's a great attribute and I courage
everyone else to live their life that
way too if they have the fortitude for
that being said get out thank you and
good job
okay hold on okay that was not actually
in yeah we gotta do justice buy-in
yeah well what's this soundbite is very
confusing so oh I meant to do to show
you guys this on the topic of fast food
there's a talk about wedding it's just
so crazy in Vegas there's a Taco Bell
chapel for 600 bucks you get a 12-pack
of tacos in a private reception area and
a bouquet made from sauce packets why is
that coffee bucks
I guess you're paying for the venue also
you only get a 12-pack come on throwing
throwing a couple more tacos would ya I
love the one-of-a-kind book care from
sauce packets one-of-a-kind baby how is
it one-of-a-kind if anyone can get it
it's by definition not only one person
is gonna buy it talk about wedding calm
you guys you heard it here
guaranteed for your wedding for your
marriage not to last
you want your erage not to last go to go
to Taco Bell wedding calm well thank you
in that was lively I was captivated
we've got the endgame review which I
want to get whoo but before we do we did
last last week we had a great
conversation about tattoos that ela
hates we started with Ben Affleck's back
tech dude by the way we have Teddy our
teddy fresh game was in here and
all the females chimed in and Neela's
defense saying wow that is the worst
back that you know the worst back tattoo
ever I was surprised I mean as bad but I
don't but I apparently that tattoo to
respectable women is like a it's like a
vagina it's like a vagina magnet I mean
it pushes away yeah yeah what do you
call that yeah it's like a vagina
repellent yeah but so he has my point
and I was very happy to hear some people
agree with me cuz I got a lot of [ __ ]
afterwards not [ __ ] no I got a lot of
bullets at me saying come on the girl
actually unanimously
there was three girls here and
unanimously they all agreed that that
the cow hole wasn't as bad and their
recent site it is because they said it's
just a dad having a laugh yeah where a
man is trying to be a badass like Yakuza
or something like your Ben Affleck dude
get on it down
you're not a Yakuza right so the fans
chimed in we got a lot of submissions at
at podcast at h3h3 productions calm and
so we've got a lot of entries here you
know people are determined to topple ban
yes so far we chant we got close we had
the MJ tattoo and the cow the cow hole
was was the closest but they didn't win
so I've got a whole new load here so ill
I think you're gonna have a run for your
money this one is fantastic okay this is
an avatar tattoo so this guy tattooed
avatar characters all over his back and
they're really bad til that's that's
really bad see you can't say this is
meant to be fun just meant to know that
no exactly this is not meant to be fine
and this this is only half of it yes so
there's more and he's on the James
Cameron Star shirtless bro why do you
like Avatar so much like hello oh I know
wait what Oh
he's wearing a thong and he avatar
tattooed it I guess wanted to do our
makeup I don't know I think it's a
tattoo his whole body look at his whole
body that guy's not messing around the
back looks like that too but the legs
kind of look like makeup mm-hmm I
appreciate that the tattoo I think he's
just that big a fan yeah into that that
oh you know why the ass crack it might
be pain it could be I actually I do
think it is pain oh wait why am i okay
it it was a different tattoo so I did
any rate how do you rate this this is
really bad the back is this is the real
and also I hate avatars yeah it's like a
double bag I don't understand avatar I
just don't get it it's like a phenomenal
but at any rate does this top bends so
don't want it's it's like on the same
level the only difference is that it's
Ben Affleck exactly I'm a bit worried we
don't have any better of Jeff or whoever
this guy is rock of course Jeff has a
habit I don't know anything about this
guy I think you're right the fact that
it's been but this is an equivalence of
awful definitely but what's your point I
think is a good one if Ben had this on
his back it would be worse the fact that
it's bad it makes everything amplify
yeah yeah okay fascinating what's next
what what the hell I think you click to
violent album okay what so what do we
have here it's what is he holding a
steering wheel
yeah he's piloting his own body I think
so he's got his head the tattoo is a
little body of him poking out of his
real body making it look like there's a
miniature of him one of him piloting his
body yellow thoughts well there is irony
here
there is but also red roses so unfunny
to like the cow hole is funnier than
this it's certainly not worth ruining
your body no it's a young guy that gave
me no I like still got he's got a life
life ahead he's got he's probably needs
to have like like imagine trying to
start a family with that thing
impossible that being said it's actually
done really well I don't know I feel I
don't have the same like repulsive
feeling as like when I saw the Avatar
right yeah the avatar once word is that
I think that the the the existence of
irony automatically lessens the blow of
of these yeah when when there is irony
present what do we got next
okay so you look chiming that's just
that's kind of why's that oh yeah that's
so sad what happened yeah probably you
have to assume assume the worst is a guy
of a of an attempted realistic portrait
of a baby on his face and then there's
just the shares are so generous the guy
I have to assume probably lost a child
that was close to him and yeah I
actually just feel bad for him yeah yeah
that's rough a lot of shading though man
yeah yeah poor guy honestly just poor
guy that's what I think this is a giant
[ __ ] smelling car
I really just tattooed a giant [ __ ] with
flies around it okay what is wrong what
it's just stupid unfunny
that's just self-loathing I mean why
don't you do that
gee whiz she must hate herself that's
what it means right still not as bad as
Ben's that also kind of just makes me
sad how about this one guy's got a big
wart on the back of his head he's got
the Michael Jordan logo don't see the
word well you're laughing so this yeah
pretty good everyone who what find this
guy gets a laugh yeah that's pretty
special to be able to do daddy Canada
the whole is head to make you laugh when
you stand behind him on your line that's
pretty special congrats to him what the
hell I won takes a little explanation
this is Justin Bieber and that is Selena
Gomez his ex-girlfriend whoa who did
that question it looks like a Native
American elder looks like the chief who
was doing his tattoos this owl is
looking is doing them team Bieber TK
what the hell okay well I don't know
this fever is too young to judge I'll
have to do some money got this it's not
Ben Affleck brand is just as Brenda
everywhere Brenda Brenda Brenda Brenda
Brenda Brenda dude if this guy's just a
stalker imagine if this guy's just
stalking the girl named Brenda and it's
not even someone he's in a relationship
with when you look at a font website and
he has Brandon every font possible bro
I'm scared for Brenda
I am worried for Brenda but um not as
been well how about this one
I love the Photoshop of the what are we
looking at it's like a leopard or
something
a leopard face and then they put the
leopards face on an actual leopard to me
it kind of has like the Chinese like you
know animation character yeah so it's
bad but it's you know not as bad it's
not the worst this is funny but so
that's a drink break across the forehead
oh I think it's a girl
100% that's just crazy
yeah a little nuts yeah I hate my mom
bro Wow again this is my mom probably
was the worst person in the world
because she probably did something awful
to him yeah what is this what am I
looking at it's good extra nipple so he
tattooed extra nipples which is pretty
strange I don't know what this is
but it's I can tell you already it's not
dog tits oh that's tough
okay so honest stomachs of dog tits and
he added six extra nipples I guess he's
a furry or something I don't know that's
true probably some that's quite bad yeah
that is quite bad
imagine if Ben Affleck had dog tits this
is guys is really yes okay good you know
Dan was like this is really hard so tell
me this guy playing what the hell I'm
looking at so gross is a super-famous
missile hit finger and what does that
mean missile hit style of music my
friend who's super at fortunately my
friend who's a musician he's in the
jokes with me he's a very talented
musician he's very open-minded too and
we came to Israel he's we both he agreed
with me and this is something that I
would never even expect him to say he's
a muse right he is probably the worst
music mm-hmm like objective huh and he's
a really open-minded guy when it comes
to music cuz on the back of his head he
has like tribal stripes and two eyes and
he's he is absolutely disgusting and I
don't know I guess at some point in his
midlife crisis he's decided that this is
gonna make him look badass and the other
thing that you should know about him is
that him and his father we're having
parties with underage girls
oh nice guy oh I heard so I've heard
about it was a big scandal yeah and I
think his father actually got like two
years in prison now huh for just having
sex with underage girls yeah or like
doing this parties but he was in it too
and this guy's still working on
everything you think that tattoo helped
him get it maybe a fifteen-year-old
found it
Oh impressive yeah what does it mean cuz
you have to when you have eyes on the
back of your neck it's like I can wash I
can see you yeah from the back of my I
don't know weird
and yeah that's a good one to bring up I
really hate them well what do you think
I mean does that rival
in May yeah I'm a so there you go after
we got Ben avatar guy in this guy he's a
celebrity and also apparently has sex
with underage girls mm-hmm I mean
apparently with his dad yeah so what's
this guy's name
yeah you gotta go done right okay y'all
go long so we may have actually found a
challenger here that one is phenomenal I
love this it's Angelina Jolie so like
seem relative it's her I guess from Tomb
Raider yeah yeah man this one actually
got submitted like ten times a bunch of
people yeah that one's pretty average
guy cuz the two are just like really
sucked here
imagine you bring that [ __ ] yeah no
problem
they're like you ready for the reveal
he's like I'm done I thought you were
just like doing the lines or something
what are we gonna eat tonight should we
get dumb Popeyes oh my god I want fum so
hungry already I started eating really
small breakfast is I have oatmeal with
no sugar nothing just water and oats a
couple of blueberries and one scrambled
egg I'm starving right now it's only
being like well I had breakfast at like
not that long line yeah and for lunch
ya know it's a great breakfast I like it
but man I'm starving
mmm as an M&M that's funny it's not on
his face or anything so I'm not gonna
hold it against him and that's just mean
come on why are we including this that's
not a bad dad ya know somebody that's
the person that submitted is the person
with the tattoo what do you think that's
crazy to me that someone
that's crazy we should send her a hat
get her up okay sir we'll sign something
yeah editor that's some real fans
dedication yeah she's a stand right
would you call that a stand-in that's
that's Stan that's Stan level there you
go we have stands I'm proud to know that
so I think we actually may have topped
Ben mm-hmm yeah
hey you gotta go down the thing is like
I don't even think that there's anybody
that will look at that - - and be like
also been can cover it with a shirt but
right this is like I think that one's
worse yeah so there you have it
congratulations - ever submitted that
you you did the impossible
his father um used his son's fame to
fork or young women including minors for
prostitution
yeah why would you stoop go in a
prostitution you're like a famous singer
I wasn't really following this story
closely because we move I'm not haven't
been following the news in Israel but I
I just looked up this article this guy
looks like such as come back it's his
dad father of singer Eyal Golan
sentenced to two years in prison
Danielle bitten 65 uses Suns fame to
procure young women including minors for
prostitution bro what the f father pop
singer I'll go along with sentence two
years in jail Wednesday he was convinced
yada yada yada and an addition to
serving his prison sentence he must pay
fifty thousand shekels that's very small
that's like that's not enough yeah
that's not a lot of money in what
probably made more than that for he
systematically arranged meetings between
his son young female fans between 15 to
20 years of age at events including the
reality television program
yeah there's oh this is afraid of our
Kelly his yeah he's grooming young girls
his Sunday
he's like a judge on one of those shows
in his really now kind of like American
Idol even though I don't know I'm not oh
no I'm not in the loop mandis this is
scumbag Ari on a new level holy smokes
yikes that makes me sick and that guy's
got eyes on the back wasn't even try to
snitch all right well that guys has come
back yeah super famous he made like some
of the biggest hits have we been going
for an hour 40 already what a little
less than that because we started
recording a little after 11:00 well
let's get on to the to the endgame shall
we oh [ __ ] okay so here's what I'm gonna
say because I don't want to spoil it for
anyone that hasn't seen it I forget that
we're not lying I was like everybody's
watching nobody's watching so here's
what I'm gonna do four people are
watching the podcast and don't want to
spoil it we're gonna start talking about
it generally speaking we're not gonna
spoil when we get into spoiler territory
I'm gonna take off my hat you should
take off your hat - okay so if my hat is
off you know we're in spoiler territory
when I put my hat back on
it's gonna be safe for you to listen
again so let's start from the top hat is
on no spoilers now generally speaking
the hype around this movie end game has
been off the chain and sanity now
obviously the I I did enjoy the first
movie hmm I thought the ending was
fantastic it was such a great talking
about infinity work yeah infinity war
was great the ending was so great
because just so impactful so dark so
unexpected and but I'm usual for these
Marvel yes you know completely unique to
that one I don't think any of them ended
dark like that you know they always find
a way to write for the good guys to win
in some way that's right and so I loved
loved loved that ending but and but I
also knew simultaneously it's gonna be
super hard to follow this up right how
are they gonna how are they not gonna
give us a like because the hero's gonna
figure this one out
what outcome would satisfy you or
surprise you like what is there it's
either another dark ending whether
that's there's no way
I wore a good yeah I figured there's no
way it's gonna be another dark ending so
so the hype was was insane the early
reviews came out and there it was like
97 percent on Rotten tomato
I'd like a 9.3 and I do be it's
currently rated I think like number 10
of all time online to be let me double
check that I am do we and game let's see
currently on IMDB Avengers endgame has a
9 point view it is rated what number 5
of all time so actually it's breaking
into the top ranks that have [ __ ] that
has not been budged in a long time
Avengers end game number five of all
time that's that's incredible
so I was really hyped to see this in
fact I didn't buy the tickets till last
night because I know I wanted to talk
about it today and I guess AMC's been
adding shows like crazy because it's
just such a gold rush I heard people
were selling tickets for like thousands
of dollars so the early screen but I got
super lucky because last night I checked
they must have just added the theater
was totally empty I got perfect seats
right in the center middle you know hi
oh and I checked five minutes later and
was completely sold out mm-hmm so we got
really lucky we had really good seats
salt last night at 7:30 one of the first
people to see it really and was very
excited to see it now this is a long
long movie three hours long yeah
no breaks what happened to giving us
breaks dude if you're gonna make a
three-hour movie you know what it is I
think I think the theaters just want
they won't that cuts into their profit
right it's like let's you have three
intermissions like come on Moses to go
buy something though and drink popcorn I
feel like people are already buying [ __ ]
but if you show intermissions all day
that's like a whole screening that
you're
gonna lose that's the only thing i can
assume because three hours is a long
time to hold it now to tell you truth
I'm not buying I want to be slipping
down so deep ops but I don't drink
anything because I'm like I don't want
to get up and pee yeah I had an
intermission I'd be so deep ah I'd be
soda pop all day bye I was thinking
about a refill on popcorn and about
halfway through the movie but you have
that impossible
there you have it sorry I disturbed him
so I have to say three hours without
intermission is pretty annoying but
that's the norm I don't know how to talk
about this without spoiling it really
nice yeah let me think there's anything
else I can say without spoiling it I can
give my overall impressions but again I
don't I don't know that that I if I was
watching that I would consider it a
spoiler if you like oh well this is so
I'm gonna take off my hat but just uh
how about just a number right right
right right so overall I got a tight I
would say in my opinion the movie is not
as good as everybody is saying it is
I've seen people losing their minds
literally losing their minds I seen
people saying you'll remember where you
were you'll be telling your
grandchildren where you were when this
movie came out I don't think it's that
good I really don't it was a good movie
it was solid the writing was great it
was satisfying I was happy that I saw it
and I mean mean he are super critical
about about movies we see it had some of
this the pitfalls I would say of normal
Marvel movies I personally don't
necessarily think that the comedy is
always working in these films to put it
mildly sometimes it's hard not to roll
your eyes at some of these suppose that
comedic scene like I'm the only one cuz
the black theater ain't no percent of
the time the theater loves it though so
I don't know people are like oh no
people love it so I don't know for me
but overall I will give this movie a B I
thought it was very good it was very
ambitious it was well done it wasn't I
wasn't in disappointed sorry I don't
know where does not go it's a P and
eight out of ten
out of 10 8 out of 10 to 8 out of 10 is
the best yeah 10 is like what's a 10
even the matrix one is a 10 pulp fiction
as far as action movies go yeah 10 is a
perfect film you know six and a half
yeah that's pretty good for you you
could have given a one so six and a half
pretty good for you huh yeah so but
didn't hate it also I'll say this if
you're a fan of the Marvel series and
you followed all these movies and all
these characters you are going to love
you are going to love this we're not
fans of yes so trust me when I say that
you will not be disappointed you are
gonna absolutely love this film and even
if you're not a fan of Marvel and you're
not invested more like me I like the
first part I'm here for the ride to
finish the story
you're still gonna enjoy mmm it's fun
it's bold its daring I think everyone
should we'll enjoy watching this film
with that being said let's take our hats
off and let's get into spoiler territory
okay thanks now here now what I want to
say about the ending of this film is
that it was how it was fairly
predictable I mean nobody should be
surprised by how this film ended mmm-hmm
I felt like almost certain that main
characters were gonna die we all knew
that and I feel like we all knew that
ant-man was going to go into the quantum
realm and and that's how they were gonna
go back in time Iron Man dying
I was like yeah so I felt like that was
just super obvious I wasn't given
especially yeah Robert Downey jr. has
been saying he wants like he's pretty
old looking old I mean he was looking
old in that shirt no no so but I'm not
saying it wasn't like successfully uh
everyone knew he was gonna die I think
the way that they killed him was was was
good it was good it was fitting it was
nice it was satisfying I also like the
way that they kind of phase
out captain Marvel's character - I
thought that was cool I was I was
thought they were setting us up for like
a whole new series where he goes and
tries to return the stones but I thought
it was great america captain america
sorry I thought was very satisfying how
he missed his thing and then he's on the
bench yeah that was I thought that was
very cool I like that but let's start
from the beginning I felt like the whole
hour and a half - first two hours its
first two hours was so boring like so
slow and unnecessary and so many jokes
per minute and like calm down with the
jokes they're not that funny
the whole first hour I want to say hour
and a half was even two hours was so a
net it was so unnecessary long like you
were saying it's like yeah oh my god it
was just so it was so boring like
everything up to the point where they
were they just go on the mission like
start going back the first moment where
I was like engaged with the film was
when like Captain America fought himself
right right which was like yeah I was
like that's cool I enjoyed that
but yeah the whole the whole ASP the
thing is I loved character development
mhm but I feel like this wasn't good
Weiser development it wasn't good
storytelling it was just uh
they were just covering their bases and
the calm and yeah I mean you have to
agree the comedy is just so corny right
I mean what did you guys think well I
mean I would say I'm a bigger Marvel fan
than it sounds like you guys are but not
but I'm not I didn't grow up with comics
I'm not like super attached to any of
these characters really you know I'd say
I'm about middle tier when it comes to
dedication of this and yeah I mean I I
agree with your overall assessment I
would rate it like an eight as well I I
mean I would have to see it again I
think I liked the last one better on it
was indisputably better yeah and I knew
when that movie ended that there was no
way the second one was gonna be able to
top it because ending was so satisfying
and it was so it was just so abrupt it
was so powerful and I knew that ii was
gonna have a happy ending so I felt like
the second one there was no way that it
was going to be able to top it now
people like it more because I just think
that people are so invested in these
characters and captain and they were so
emotional about all these characters
dying off and by the way let so let's
talk about the characters that died
first of all Scarlett Johansson's
character I don't even know what the
point her character has never done
anything and all of the Marvel movies
same with Hawkeye
that's one scene they could have both
jumped off for all I care but they they
sacrifice the least interesting
character in the whole series and so
that didn't have any impact on me other
Hawkeye is less interesting than her I
thought they were gonna kill Hawk Eye
but they could have both jumped off both
characters are stupid the dudes running
away with a bow and arrow
like there's a scene where you planning
games with a bone arrow I'm so sick of
this character
you're fighting a what next to Thor god
of thunder and you're shooting a bow and
arrow dude doesn't even use a gun like
at least get a rifle or something this
guy sucks
he's the worst hero sorry I do want to
say that the whole ending part was
pretty cool and epic how they went for
it and like everyone was there
yes everyone that was pretty cool I
agree it was fine dongs bro it paid off
really fun I thought it was it was gonna
watch it was so satisfying because in
the beginning of the film they go they
find Thor and or they find Thanos and
they kill him I thought that was kind of
cool yeah I just don't like all the
filler like why make it three hours well
they start strong unnecessary they go
and they kill Thanos and I was like wow
crazy and actually I was disappointed I
was like man I'd really like Fanus as a
character but then they they find a way
to bring him back yeah and it's very
satisfying because you get to see the
whole armies battling it out yeah those
comes and he brings us all army and I
thought they know I left a nose fight
seems he's just such a badass I love
watching a fight and he looks so
impossibly strong yeah he's like the
ultimate what's his backstory it's like
the ultimate warlord
dan tell me this I had this uncanny the
end of that movie was identical to the
end of one punch man season 1 you got
the spaceship over earth the armies the
spaceship was shooting with [ __ ] down
out the armies below ok then Captain
Marvel shows up and destroys the ship in
one hit
you've got vana it's like isn't it so
uncanny it was like uncanny
it was crazy see this is where our
unfamiliarity with the comics may hurt
us though because I don't know I mean
one punch man may have been paying
homage to to this I'm not accusing him
of stealing no I get it but you're right
it's a very similar kind of scenario it
was freakin uncanny
anyway the ending the battle scene was
fantastic super satisfying Doctor
Strange shows up and portals everyone in
and Tony Stark and he looks at me
because it was great now and I don't
like in the beginning how antman that's
what I was gonna say ok how Enderman is
just like I figured it out with time
travel and everything everyone is like
no way you gotta be kidding and then
Tony Stark over one night figures it out
wouldn't see they they put the emphases
in the wrong places they spent two hours
on these dumbass stupid jokes like how
much time did they spend at fat Thor's
cabin or like yeah there was another one
there was a huge long aside before Thor
with another character I don't remember
but like so then you spent all this time
and fat Thor's cabin trying to make
cheap laughs and then meanwhile Hulka
being like yeah yeah exactly
and then meanwhile you have Captain
Marvel literally just showing up she's
just this convenient plot point she
shows up Tony Stark's in the middle
space stranded kept-kept
was like hey baits me okay we're back
bye it's like oh that was easy to
resolve you know they they set it up at
the end of Captain Marvel's movie which
is again like why you you know it's a
strength and a weakness of these movies
you have to kind of like know all of
them especially for this since it's the
conclusion there was like a post-credits
scene at the end of Captain Marvel where
she shows up so I think it's implied
they sent her to go find Iron Man that's
not in the movie you have to have
watched another mess even a host credit
though like that's not yeah it wasn't
even the post-credits scene I feel like
that could have used development because
she just shows up and she brings him
back yeah and then he's back and that's
it I was like because they set up this
whole a big thing like Tony Stark is
lost in space it's like everything's
[ __ ] nope whatever mark just showed up
and saving real quick and she's gone by
I was like okay and then she bounces
again I think yeah I think she shows up
conveniently at the end of the film and
she's like all men fight Thanos roof
economic blow up the ship okay bye I'm
gonna get it's like oh okay what's the
problem with characters like that is
she's the same she's got the same
problem with Superman where they're just
too strong they have to figure out a way
to like get her out of the way what is
it she could just fix everything
Superman by himself is a great character
because his vulnerabilities are not his
strengths
mm-hmm right it's his his weaknesses are
his personal relationships and right and
his vote and that he wants to save all
of humanity right but Captain Marvel was
was never developed and in any
interesting way as far as I can tell her
character is pretty dumb and she's like
well there's a lot of other plants and
he's saving it's like Hello
fantasies gonna kill half the people in
the universe how is anything else more
important than that Captain Marvel
you're worthless oh well there's other
planets that need saving
then we'll talk about the whole universe
here okay whatever
so she doesn't exist in the film and
then ant-man's like guys he shows up
guys
he doesn't know science or anything he's
just like had considered time-travel and
then they're like and then there's like
a million jokes about back in the future
yeah okay it's not like other whatever
we've spent a half hour joking about
back to the future but is it kind of
stupid he's not a scientist
he doesn't provide technology or
anything because they rebuild it as far
as I can tell he just like has any but I
just got out of the quantum Oh has
anybody considered that we can use we
can build a time machine
oh it's been five years and all of a
sudden ant-man just with the brilliant
we should build a time machine okay
pretty much that's how that plot point
went like I've considered that plot
point more interesting they kept a
marvel saving Iron Man plot point more
interesting IRA men develop in the time
machine
he just solved that in a day and then
meanwhile we've got these super boring
dumb unfunny scenes that run forever
yeah so that was my like Thor dabbing
you didn't think that was really fun for
dabbing Thor fat Thor drunk oh my god
for tonight was actually in the movie I
did I cringe I have a nose here I was
taking notes the whole tour looking like
Big Lebowski was kinda like mm-hmm
I totally agree I mean they even made it
explicit if they shouldn't have made it
explicit they call him Lebowski at one
point I was like come on we we got it
yeah they're like wink wink wink in chat
if they hadn't pointed it out I might
have been okay with this one scene I
hate by the way he goes Thor's brooding
he's so upset
Captain Marvel shows up and she's just
such a badass and he calls his hammer
and it's it was a right past her head
and then he goes and she doesn't flinch
she doesn't flinch and he goes I like
this woman and then she does this which
is the one thing I hate in all movies
when they go they go from serious to
slightly smiling it's the worst movie
trope and this scene everybody there the
trailer I find beyond so unfunny so
corny I like this one and then this okay
whatever
awful hated it oh there was one guy in
the theater who kept by the legend no
one there was a bunch of Audi ads they
were stupid cuz like I don't know why
all the Avengers are
zipping around in like freshly polished
perfect outies we're like really nice
rims yeah they like pull up like a car
commercial like and then the lights hit
the there's like a flare you know what I
mean in the camera and the Audi is like
artificially polished and you see the
logo perfectly and they all get out the
Audi and it's like it's like a car it's
like a literal car commercial so our
product placement like oh they're
driving oh they're an Audi no it's a car
commercial like you know that Audi
executives like had perfect control over
this and they're like no we got to
reshoot this we got the cars gotta being
framed for three second I think how much
money they coughed up for that - bro I
hope it was a [ __ ] [ __ ] and there
was the same wind ax body the oh my god
what'd they go there was this one thing
that really pissed me off were floors
like there's a scene where Thor it's
like someone asked him were you did you
use Axe body spray
oh is it Captain America somebody one of
the heroes oh it was actually it was
Iron Man Iron Man yes
which seems kind of out of character for
him I feel like Iron Man wouldn't use ax
bodies why have used Axe body spray it's
so weird to bring a company like that
into this world like why even go there
how much did axe pay them yeah certainly
it was a product placement ad though and
it was just like such an eye roll it's
like bro this movie's gonna make so much
money there's no way that Axe body spray
paid you enough that this that this is
immortalized Axe body spray is now
immortalized in this film you know what
I'm saying it takes you out of the
moment to me it was a body spray and it
had no plot relevance it had nothing it
was just like oh did use Axe body spray
yes I was stinking that's the whole
scene and now Axe body spray is
immortalized because they pay them like
a million how much do they pay I mean
seriously I mean yeah they paid I don't
know and then fortnight is actually in
it like flowers playing thort night
fortnight and I was like oh my god
fortnight is an every [ __ ]
thing no crazy like that just dates it
to you know when everybody's over
fortnight and it's just you know totally
passe a couple years
don't be like youth such a bad call oh
you wrote this one he let there's beer
in the ship because okay they spend all
this time trying to convince tor to join
them and he was like I'm over it I'm not
going with you
yeah and he's now in this like he gained
weight and he's drinking and he's
playing video games yeah and then they
one of the characters had this so
predictable line there is bear in the
shape and then thaw respond if he's on
board
whatever his response was like what kind
yeah and then you know that it's going
with yeah it's just these it's these
lines and tape the people like it that's
how I don't know what to say but forced
yeah there's there's weird plot holes
like Thor goes back to his previous time
line runs into his mom and then before
he leaked cuz his hammer was destroyed
in one of the previous ones he calls the
hammer and a parallel universe and then
bounces so presumably he stole the
hammer from himself and now in that
universe that Thor no longer has a
hammer uh that one that one they address
at a day dressed at the end captain when
Captain America goes to bring all the
gems battle he brought their armor twins
a hammer so I think it's implied he
returned like he returns the gym ok
today you know they were pretty
consistent with the time-travel stuff
the the part that I think is a plot I
don't I don't want to say a hundred
percent because some Marvel nerds gonna
be like no you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about you make sense but
Captain America being there as an old
man at the end is that a giant pothole I
mean cuz like the whole thing was that
when they go back it creates a parallel
universe and so he goes back at the end
to live out the rest of his life with
with his one true love and then lives
his whole rest of his life up until that
point it doesn't that mean I guess there
was always to Captain America like he
was in hiding the whole time yeah what
does nobody ever recognized him because
he's like a very gues famous person yeah
I guess they were they were exist
coexisting yeah but like
I'm vague but yeah in one of the
previous Captain America movies didn't
he like make out or have sex with the
daughter of that woman
[ __ ] yeah but I'm ended up but now they
got married so like did he bang his
daughter is that the implication I'd
like wait what a weird thing yeah in one
forget which Captain America was but in
one of them there's a character that is
she's the daughter of what's-her-name
Peggy I forget see yeah that is what
somebody's gonna be like now that is a
time travel stuff you know but yeah I
think but that was what bothered me
about it because like for the most part
they they followed their own rules
pretty consistently right up to the end
and then when he shows up there I'm like
ah that kind of blows all of it yeah
interesting because well presumably when
he goes back and when he goes back he
creates a parallel timeline but then
they wouldn't be there if he did right
because the whole the whole thing that
kept emphasizing you can't you can't
change the present by changing the past
it'll just create like a difference
right alternate universe and so the fact
that he's there at the end means that he
was always there and that just kind of
that to me kind of breaks the logic of
the whole thing I don't know I don't
know it doesn't ruin the movie or
anything but I was thinking about it
when I was driving home and I was just
like that kind of doesn't sit right with
me he was there right I like the idea of
it I thought it was cool but I see what
you're saying and it's almost like they
just needed to write his character out
real fast right yeah you know and fix
everything conveniently to they fixed
all the plot holes and then create the
biggest one also was that black guy how
was he gonna become Captain America's
he's super strong like Captain thought
he was just like I think I'm dude with a
regular dude he's got a suit what the
hell he can do with that shield maybe
he'll get powered up by somebody I don't
know we'll find out and Captain America
for which I'm sure is coming yeah
Captain America for now he's black title
Sam
Sam is his name right yeah I don't know
what his superhero name is though and
I've seen like all of you isn't he the
guy that doesn't have wings and [ __ ]
he's not even any time like Kalkan yeah
I had it all right so Falcon so how the
hell is he gonna be Captain America
he doesn't need super-strength because
he's got a badass suit I guess and that
but they set it up too like they set it
up like he always wanted this shield to
you know I mean you know what he's like
ran the other guy thank you yeah what I
don't know oh you put your hat on
we're in spoiler territory so we're done
all right we're done we're done
so overall the movie was that was funny
I find anybody to watch it fans of
Marvel are sure to enjoy every second of
it yeah and people who are not even fans
of Marvel who watch the first movie are
going to enjoy it is a it's a cinematic
feat it really is yeah they'll say all
that because it sounds like we're
nitpicking it slam I can I totally know
it it's for sure a good movie yeah and
also I mean take your hat back off real
quick because I gotta say something no
[ __ ]
spoiler alert spoiler alert again dude
the the scene where [ __ ] Captain
America got the hammer that was hype as
[ __ ] like yeah that it cool super
[ __ ] cool and I invite all the other
flaws the moments like that it
definitely makes it worse
well isn't it I know there's like a big
it's a lower that Captain America was
the only one that got to use well then
they set it up in a previous movie he
like only moved it at one time yeah yeah
so yeah it was it was well supported it
made sense and yeah it was a very it was
it was very good I enjoyed that part
even without following the whole yeah
lore
yeah I agree I thought that was great I
thought was great fantastic
especially since he kind of got shafted
in the last movie he's like barely and I
can hear your vaping Dan alright hats on
alright so overall well I got a I got do
I have to wrap it up again no we got it
we're good
anybody that didn't want spoilers really
should have just bailed so in short it's
great for anyone and once you go watch
it fans of Marvel are gonna freaking
love it people who are not fans murder
are gonna still enjoy it yeah like you
said it sounds like we're nitpicking
but I mean we are nitpicking I gave it
an 8 so I mean right yeah it wasn't a 10
but it was an 8 mm-hmm a good film
everyone should watch it everyone is
gonna watch it anyway so I love that
rant billion dollars in the box office
yeah I think it's gonna do it the hype
is crazy
it's insane I also think that I left
annals as a character too and the actor
he played I mean Thanos is just one of
the best one of the best villains ever
great actor great execution he looks
great on screen yeah he's just it's just
an awesome character very very
satisfying I don't I think that
everyone's gonna enjoy this so there you
have it
Age 3 movie review Gabi SH so many
reviews today from food I'm so hungry
let's go eat so that about wraps it up
guys don't forget to run over to Teddy
fresh comm our new collection is out
today and it's going fast fast hot hot
hot hot good [ __ ] great [ __ ] very happy
very proud of Chloe we put out there
today and I hope you guys enjoy it I
hope you have a fantastic we thank you
guys for enjoying it and supporting the
brand the dream yeah happy weekend I'm
sorry it's so weird that we're not live
but hey that's what it is right I guess
but we're not out we're not cutting this
is still the same thing yeah I did say
the N word a little bit back we'll cut
we did cut that part but you wouldn't
know unless I told you didn't I yeah
thank you have a fantastic weekend my
Haitian army and oh enjoy and game yeah
remember we got next week bogi one of
the Thursday right yeah I'm Thursday
continually and forever always one of
the best guests that we ever have here a
wonderful upload it on Finance yeah
that's that makes sense I'd be good um
looking forward to that guys got some
new teeth we're gonna be talking about
that
all right I have a great weekend and joy
and and a big ol Papa bless to yellow
thank you for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]